السلام عليكم
ما هو المنكوب
الزراعه الذكيه تجربه قمنا بها بالبصره هي
التجربه الاولى وكانت تجربه رياديه راح
اتحدث لكم
بزياره هذا الشخص نائب رئيس الاكاديميه
الفيتناميه للعلوم
الفكره يمكن انا حتى يسال بها السماء
تذكره بس هو مطالنا حلول قد تكون بسيطه
جدا وسهله يعني كل ما نقول عندنا مشكله
التلوث عندنا مشكله
في هذا الرجل هو اللي ينطعننا
الشراره الاولى للتجربه
بعدها تصلب منظمات اقليميه قريبه ومؤسسات
في دول مجاوره قدرنا نلتقي لاشخاص قدموه
لنا الدعم هم الباحثين المتخصصين في زراعه
نبات
ما هو النبات
السنه القديمه والجزر
هذه النبات في النشر مالته استراليا
وزليندا دول شرق اسيا بنجلاديش الهند
باكستان
يعني كثير من دول الشرق اسيا وطبعا
بالخليج العربي موجود بكثره في الامارات
وعمان والبحرين والسعوديه
هذا النبات
وهذه النقطه الاساسيه اللي احنا اعتمدناها
جبنا نبات سمارت
خمس او ست نباتات اخرى
طبعا ثلاثه الى خمسه بالمئه قدره التبادل
للغازي مضاعفه عن الغابات المطريه
الاستوائيه نباتي حقق ارباح تقارن بال
يعني تقريبا 180 بليون دولار سنويا
120.000 انسان او مليان انسان عفوا يعيشون
في هذه المناطق التي تتواجد بها غابات
ايضا هو وقود بديل لبعض الدول
ثلاثه الاف نوع من الاسماك 3000 نوع من
الاسماك تعيش في هذه البيئات فتخيله ممكن
انه همم حجم الاصناف اللي ممكن انه تعيش
في هذه البيئات طبعا ثلاث ارباع
خلينا نقول مخازن الاسماك بالعالم بالكره
الارضيه معرضه الى التدمير او انهيار
بسبب همم زوال الغابات
الا قيمه عاليه في مجال السياحه ممكن احنا
نعتبر هذه المناطق مناطق سياحيه ممكن نخلق
من عندها محميات طبيعيه ممكن تحقق انها
ارباح بهذا المجال ايضا النبات مهم في سحب
كميات كبيره من الملوثات على قدره كبيره
همم يعني التعامل مع هذه الملوثات اللي
تتواجد بالمئه
90 او 70 الى 90% من طاقه الامواج يعني
باعتبار هذا وتر بريكس يعني ممكن نعتبره
مصدات للامواج اللي ممكن يتعرض لها
السواحل خاصه اثناء حصول التغير المناخي
وارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر
طبعا السلسله الغذائيه لنبات المنغروف جدا
مهمه فهو العنصر
الطاقه الاساسي الاول بالفوتين بالنسبه
للغذائيه للمجتمع البحري للاسماك في بدايه
تشتغل للمحللات
وبعدها الديدان وممكن اكرابس
والشوران يعني همم
سلسله الغذائيه
ايضا بالنسبه للفود ويب هو مهم جدا يخلق
شبكه غذائيه واسعه ممكن تيجي الطيور
الحيوانات البريه ويعني وتعتاش على ما
موجود من احياء في هذه المنطقه
مثل ما قلنا الكلايم تشينج او يعني
رجوليتر بالنسبه للتنظيم غاز سي او 2
وتعادل الى ثلاثه الى خمس مرات اين نبات
ثاني وهو بالتالي اذا زرعنا في البيئه
مالتنا راح يكون بديل عنك كثير من
النباتات اللي بدات تقل وهو مقاومه لكافه
الظروف للتلوث يعني لكل المشاكل اللي ممكن
تتعرض لها التربه والمياه
اليه خزنه الكربون يكون بالجدار
طبعا 90% مثل ما قلنا من طاقه الامواج هذه
تجربه توضح انه كيف النبات الى قدره على
تنظيم
وكسر طاقه الامواج والتالي توصل الى زيرو
في نهايه التجره الزوم اللي ينمو بالنطاق
الحراري 30 درجه شمال وجنوب خط الاستواء
وبالتالي فهو نبات استوائي احنا بالنسبه
للعراق يقع في اعلى خط يعني اعلى حدود
النمو النبات وكثير من علماء النبات رضه
ومشروع وقالوا هذا مستحيل انه بالبيئه
مالتنا بس احنا جربناه يعني راح تشوفون
التجربه هذه الصين فين السائده بالمنطقه
همم
لونها اخضر غامق والافيسين
بدي انام التجربه في
الفاو يعني زرعنا تقريبا 100 نبته كلها
ماتت فشلت التجربه فشل تام معها يعني
اسماء رجعنا جبنا مره ثانيه حصلنا بذور
قدرنا نعاملها بمعاملات معينه
وبدايه تجربه بسيطه جدا ما كلفتنا حتى
100000 بس هي كانت التجربه المفصليه اللي
على اساس قدرنا انه انت قرار بامكانيه
الى مرحله الزجاجيه اهلنا بيت الزجاج
والزرعنا مجموعه من النباتات تقريبا
بالالفته
بدينا بالتعاون مع الشركه العامه للموانزو
زودتنا بارض وقدرنا قدرت تقدم لنا دعم
زرعنا النباتات
وبدات تنمو خلال اربعه اشهر كان النمو جدا
رائع وصولا الى مرحله انفجر خزان وقود
وفشلت التجربه كل النباتات اللي موجوده
بالمنطقه ماء انتقلنا الى موقع ثانيه
الشركه العامه للمونيه ايضا صار تربيتي
عالي والنتيجه اللي حركه السفن ايضا اهم
فشله التجربه مره ثانيه رجعنا للموقع
الاول بعد انه سالم المؤثر
على دعم من همم يعني وزاره البيئه وكثير
من المؤسسات وحتى الحكومه المحليه مقدمه
انك كثير من التسهيلات
نجح النبات نجاح كبير وبدينا وصلنا الى
مرحله الاظهار بس ما عقدت عندنا ثمار
ننتظر ان شاء الله السنه القادمه اذا يعني
يتحققت ان فرصه وقدرنا النباتات تكون
امهات اللي بيدور وبالتالي راح نستغني عن
موضوع الاستيراد البدور النبات الى قدره
لسحب الاملاح لاحظوا هاي كميه الاملاح
اللي موجوده
عظيمه جدا اي مستوى الحين ممكن يعيش يوم
بالتالي اذا مستقبل البصره كانت خلينا
نقول لسان للحين ارتفاع وتحولت ان اياها
الى مالحه احنا عندنا
نباتات ممكن تعيش بهذه البيئه هذه طبعا
صوره المنطقه اللي بالاتفاق مع همم بيئه
المنطقه الجنوبيه وزاره البيئه همم يعني
احنا حاليا يعني همم
هذه المنطقه المحميه راح تكون محميه كبيره
جدا هي اصلا المنطقه تنوع الطيار
اا يعني في نهايه الامر الموضوع متروك لنا
ولها اصحاب القرار هل نترك بصمه
للاجيال القادمه هل راح نقدم شيء جديد
ممكن نتعاون نسويه ان شاء هذه المحميه انه
الاولادنا والاحفادنا او لا نترك الامور
الى المجهول
انا هذا اللي عندي شكرا جزيلا لكم شكرا
لكم
[تصفيق]